fassungslose gesichter in rio de janeiro
brasilianische fußball fans können nicht
glauben dass iris lsv aus der wm
geflogen ist
aus der traum vom sechsten titel dabei
hatten sie sich so danach gesehnt
die menschen in brasilien war hier
zurzeit schwere zeiten durch die leute
haben so sehr die daumen gedrückt und
jetzt haben wir verloren
das wird eine schlimme absolut in samba
laune zeigten sich dagegen die
belgischen fans in brüssel bejubelten
tausende bis spät in den abend in 2 1
sieg ihrer mannschaft die bei einigen
eher als wm geheimtipp gehandelten roten
teufel haben sich zu einem favoriten
gemausert
ich glaube fest daran dass sie den titel
gewinnen können aber dafür müssen sie
spiele wie das hier machen sie haben das
wahnsinnig gut gemacht aber es gab auch
ein paar spieler die heute nicht ganz
auf der höhe waren ein eigentor von
fernandinho hatte belgien in der ersten
viertelstunde in führung gebracht kevin
de bruyne schoss in der 31 minute dann
das 2 0 mit dem belgien in die zweite
halbzeit zog rund 20 minuten vor schluss
wurde es im stadion von kasan dann noch
mal spannend brasiliens renato augusto
verkürzte auf 2 1 aber alles kümmern und
daumendrücken half nichts
brasilien ist raus und die belgier
treffen in ihrem ersten wm halbfinale
seit 1986 auf einen besonderen gegner
und nachbarn frankreich